how's this for a baptism by fire just
three days after being sworn into
congress to represent
michigan's third district republican
freshman peter meyer
found himself and his colleagues trapped
without security
in the bowels of the capitol building
while a riot that
ultimately claimed five lives raged all
around
the following week he was one of just 10
republicans and the
only first term member of the gop who
voted to impeach donald trump
whom he had supported on the campaign
trail meyer's vote to impeach led to a
narrowly felt center vote from his own
state's gop
and immediate announcements that he will
be primaried in 2022
the 33 year old iraq war veteran who
says his
military training helps him maintain
focus is filling the seat vacated by
former libertarian party congressman
justin amash
whose policy views he shares on a broad
range of issues
meyer told reason why he believes in
limited government
economic freedom and individualism why
he's against
out-of-control stimulus spending and
military adventurism
and how he plans to combat the craziness
he sees both on the right
and the left in the house of
representatives
representative peter meyer thanks for
talking to reason
thank you for having me on nick a
pleasure uh let's start with
uh you know you are one of just 10
republicans
in the house of representatives who
voted to impeach trump the second time
and from what i've read you're the only
first termer to do that
why did you vote to impeach donald trump
your party's president
yeah well you know that that question is
something that i know a lot of my
constituents have been asking i
i've had a number of town halls and uh
have heard a number of very impassioned
uh opinions um you know to me is a
pretty simple question
of you know is the republican party a
party of rule of law
a party that believes in accountability
or is it one that puts a personality
you know above principles um
the house's role in an impeachment is
pretty narrow uh we look at the
article or articles in this case there's
only one of impeachment that are laid
before us and have to make a judgment if
we believe it to be
true and accurate and then if so if
impeachment you know is a reasonable uh
decision to make obviously this was one
that was politically
um less than optimal uh i did not want
in my first
10 days in office to impeach a president
of my own party
but the fact of the matter is january 6
and the assault on the capital would
have never happened
if it wasn't for president trump um
propagating
two lies one that november 3rd was a
landslide victory for donald trump that
was stolen
and two that january 6th was a day to
stop the steel
and those two lies which could have
easily just
faded away into nothing were continually
amplified legitimized and propagated by
donald trump and it resulted in the
deaths of five americans
um uh the defiling of the seat of our
democracy
and and frankly sent a message that we
absolutely
it sent a message that you know our our
first our section one
um powers can be undermined
by the executive so the the third
district of michigan is becoming the
the impeachment seat right because
justin amash who you replaced when he
chose not to uh
run for re-election had voted to uh to
impeach trump a couple years ago or
whatever
um you like him are taking a huge amount
of guff from constituents you mentioned
some
town halls and stuff but so far you uh
you know it's been announced one of your
primary contenders from this past
election cycle has said he's going to
primary you
you may be censured by the state gop
this has happened to other republican
congressmen
who voted to impeach members of congress
how do you feel about that
um you know and i guess sorry to
step in on my own question first are you
are you elected like is your philosophy
that you're elected to reflect your
conscience or that
or the will of your constituents um you
know and then
how are you gonna deal with it if your
your own state party says hey
you're you're in big trouble buster yeah
so my philosophy to answer that question
is that
you're elected to exercise your judgment
um and you're elected
you know based off of the the principles
and the values that you espouse during
the campaign
but then ultimately the job of a
representative is not just to represent
you know the opinion of the mass
in a point in time right or else what's
the point i mean just take a poll
figure out where people are and then
have that be the direction
i mean there will be accountability for
the decisions that i made
um and that we'll we'll see in either
the august 2021 primary or in the
november
general election but at the end of the
day
i have to i think every constituent has
to
elect folks that they trust their
judgment and even if they don't
necessarily agree with it at least
reach a point of understanding that's
one of the reasons why i have been
very accessible we're actually the first
congressional office to do a live
zoom town hall where constituents could
ask questions via video
it took us a little longer than i wanted
to and i can't believe we were the first
to do it
but i think that's that's what i owe the
constituents but
i think it was uh edmund burke who said
and i'm gonna i'm gonna butcher this in
the paraphrasing
you know that you do your constituents a
disservice if you
you know sacrifice your judgment for
their opinion
because opinions change and opinions are
dependent on
um perspectives and facts that can be
ever fluid
i you know it's also fascinating you
when you were running for office you
said you were you supported donald trump
as president what um you know what did
you like about him
before uh you know that you know before
election day when he
he kind of flipped and said no no i had
to win because
i voted for myself everybody i know
everybody in my family i think voted
for me uh you know and then went on this
two-month bender of you know propagating
uh bs about uh the the election being
stolen but
what did you like about trump before uh
november third
yeah you know i during the campaign
to me the easiest way to win a primary
is also the easiest way to lose
in a general in a competitive seat right
i
i was and remain you know a fan of many
of the policies
i remain remain a fan of
shaking up a staid system of fighting
against a status quo that reverts to the
me
and i give and have given donald trump
credit for that but
to me um there's a difference between
there's a difference between being able
to to effect positive change from that
and
bring in a moment of institutional ruin
um
that really put our democracy in peril
and that's where again
um rhetoric and bluster is is
a something we've always had in our
political system
um but where that trends into political
violence and frankly into an assault
on you know the seat of our legislature
um
and into threats and intimidation not
just
um you know banter you know that's a
line that can't be crossed and frankly
when i was sitting there
um after having evacuated the house
chambers on january 6th and then i saw
his first video
and had been waiting for donald trump to
do something to say something i mean
this these were
his people this was a moment when the
country needed someone to step up and
lead
um he abandoned his office he
you know abandoned responsibility he uh
he shrunk from that moment
um and to me he also betrayed all the
accomplishments of his past four years
of
middle east peace deals of operation
warp speed of deregulation of a
burgeoning economy before covet that
you know had wage growth even at the
lowest level um
all of that was wiped away that's not
how the history books will remember him
can you uh handicap do you think he will
be
convicted in the uh in the trial in the
senate
i don't think it's outside the bounds of
possibility but i
am certainly not expecting that um
senators will rise to the moment
i think there's been back peddling of
enormous magnitude
you know they're backpedaling so hard
that the chain's off the sprocket and
dragging on the ground i mean it's
really something to behold
do you worry about being censured by the
uh
michigan uh republican party in your
home state that will that affect you or
what
would will that have any real impact you
know paul henry
who held this seat
in the late 1980s and early 1990s was
censured
by the local party gop because he
voted against reagan's mx missile
program
um accenture is
a strongly worded letter um i respect
the opinion
of uh those folks but at the end of the
day
they're not the folks who sent me to
washington so
you know it's it's funny to say like in
your first two weeks in
office that voting to impeach
a president for the second time yeah is
like
not even the most interesting thing that
happened to you you were
you know i mean a couple days after you
were sworn in you had the riot
show up in cap in the capitol and you
talked with my colleague matt welch
about that just
a day or two after it happened uh with a
little bit more time
and distance um can you describe what it
was like to be
inside the capitol when it was actually
being kind of
overrun by a bunch of crazy people
you know i i spent about three years
between iraq where i was an interrogator
and a source handler
you know with the army so as a combatant
in afghanistan where i spent time as a
conflict analysis
analyst for the humanitarian aid
community
and that led me well
right now i feel pretty comfortable that
i could land at an airport anywhere in
the world and
could figure out how to not die um but
in that moment
it was just a sense of disbelief
that um
a sense of disbelief that everything was
kind of colliding right that the
rhetoric
and um the the insanity that we had
witnessed and the the creation of an
alternate reality
um that that was being played out in
real time and and i had
i had talked to folks who were coming to
the rally um
i had listened to uh constituents who
wanted me to
overturn the election i was trying to
unders
to explain that well republicans are in
the minority in the house so even if
every republican did this which would be
a terrible precedent to set it still
would fail
and then there was just this this utter
disconnect um
and frankly i think that disconnect
extended to donald trump who
you know had created his own
worldview that was wholly divorced from
any constitutional statutory or real
world precedent
but it was just utterly bizarre i mean i
watched the full
speech he gave on the ellipse right and
i just had that sinking feeling
whereas well if i'm gonna go to the
capitol it's probably the
safest place to be is in the house
chamber which um
did not ultimately end up being accurate
but also just i mean is this
the us um is this how things go and
by the way where the hell was the
planning on the front end
right well uh two things about that
first can you you you've been critical
of the way that the capitol hill police
not you know not that not the rank and
file members or you know the
the beat cops as it were but the
planning what went wrong there
and um do you still you know hold them
accountable for
basically being missing in action i i do
hold them accountable i
i've been in situations and i've done um
you know threat assessments and physical
security
you know assessments of structures and
facilities
um i think i think there's
you could draw a straight line between
the lack of preparedness
and the lack of mobilization of the
national guard on january 6th
and what we saw over the summer
especially with the blm protest
outside the white house and the clearing
of lafayette square
um i guarantee you if the national guard
would have been mobilized
and nothing would have happened nancy
pelosi would be accusing donald trump of
trying to stage a coup
and of intimidating lawmakers you know i
could
put myself in those in the position of
those planners
and come to come to see why they made
the decisions they did which proved
horrendous in hindsight but i think
we're done in good faith
at the moment do you think they were
they were going
easy because of the negative response to
a kind of a more muscular
uh inter intervention during the summer
months
i think i think it was partially that
and
you know i had told
a number of folks you know if you look
at the businesses that are boarding up
their windows ahead of the election
you know they weren't boarding up their
windows because they were worried
that biden was going to win and and so
we had seen
over the summer that and i
it's partially political violence i mean
there was more to it than just politics
but
um how that had led to riots in the
street
and become a little bit nerd to the fact
that
it was going in one direction and where
i think it was different was that
i and why i had a real sinking feeling
going into
it and i'd actually given an interview
the day before where i'd said i was very
worried about the outbreak of violence
that could occur and
um and i left that interview thinking ah
was i too honest was that
and then i probably didn't go far enough
in retrospect but
it was just that sense that the the rage
and the violence
on the left was sort of omnidirectional
versus this had been specifically
focused
on overturning the results of election
on preventing congress from delaying
certification
and that's why you know terms like
sedition and insurrection
come into the fore because it wasn't
just you know
obviously looting and burning of a city
is a horrific act
and causes tremendous emotional and
physical destruction
um and lives you know dozens of lives
were lost as well
you know but there's also a very
specific threat
when it is directed at upsetting the
functioning of the government and
particularly preventing a transfer of
presidential power which we have always
had and prided ourselves in
in this country did you fear for your
life uh you've talked about
you know the reality of having to wear
uh you know bulletproof vest to go to
work
um are you still doing that or and you
know and in the moment were you actually
uh afraid for your life i was afraid in
retrospect
i was less fearful when we were in the
house chamber than when we had evacuated
and we were wandering in the tunnels
and trying to flag down police officers
who are running in every which direction
and saying what the hell are we doing
here
i mean to me that was one of the most
dispiriting things was you know the cold
war you have
mount weather and you have the
greenbrier
these evacuation locations for
continuity of government
um you know hundreds of millions maybe
billions of dollars have been spent on
you know protecting us from external
threats and then
you know there was no safe room there
was no oh here's your evacuation
location we just
scattered in groups of you know 10 or 20
or 30 or 40 lawmakers
and so as you know i i'd say the moment
where i was most
uncertain was when we were just
wandering through the tunnels underneath
the capitol
knowing that some of the buildings they
were connected to had been breached
and were no longer secure or had been
evacuated and
you know if uh if the people who were
storming
the capital and sending facebook
messages saying oh the members of
congress are in the tunnels three levels
down
you know go find them if they had found
us
i don't know what would have happened
you know let's talk about uh
the future of the republican party uh a
bit you know
at this point what does being a
republican mean to you you know why
why did you run as a republican rather
than a democrat what what's the essence
of
of your vision of the republican party
yeah i would say three
fundamental values limited government
economic freedom and
individual liberty uh and frankly
defining that
against a a party and a worldview that
tends towards centralization tends
towards federalization
uh tends towards nationalization you
know i i'm a big proponent of
subsidiarity
i think if you look at organizations
that function and function well
there are those that devolve power down
that that treat
individuals with the degree of of agency
and respect
with accountability that they deserve i
mean that's how you get positive
outcomes
and and to me i mean unions are the
antithesis of that
um and whatever party tends towards you
know enabling
um elements like teachers unions is
probably going to be one that i'm on the
opposite side of
but you know i think the other
interesting thing in our political
spectrum right now is just
the the tribalization and the
self-sorting
on any number of issues and how that
ultimately obscures
whatever fundamental values or
principles those parties may have had
into just an assemblage of policy points
that sometimes are wildly out of step
with those intrinsic beliefs
or or those intrinsic beliefs just
aren't there well can i
can i challenge you a little bit on that
because uh from my reading of uh you
know and and i want to go through some
kind of basic issues because
um there's a lot there and and i find a
lot to uh
be uh interested in in your positions
but on
to begin with um you are pro-life right
and should that be you know does that
contravene
a kind of republican ideal of limited
government
and of devolving decisions down to the
individual level
the to me the the the question there
hinges on
you know whose life is value right if
that that sense of of of due process
uh that sense of protection and this is
where if you believe that a life is
created at birth then
then it's an irrational belief if you
believe that life starts at conception
then
that is a period where those rights are
imbued
in that created form um and then that i
think is where
a lot of the disconnect comes in in that
argument right
uh you have been you served in the
military i mean you
you served in in uniform in uh in iraq
and you uh but you are you've been
critical of uh you know what are being
called the forever wars and it's kind of
disturbing that everybody uses that
phrase but very few people do anything
about it
why are you critical of you know ongoing
conflicts uh with american presence that
at this point are lasting decades i mean
simply put
it's wild to me that i was in iraq a
decade ago
now granted our presence there and the
troops on the ground have kind of ebbed
and flowed
but it's always been reactive and we've
never actually had a fundamental vision
for what we think
the region should be that was actually
paired with what we were willing to
invest in order to see that through
are in in in november the um
sorry in october the post 9 11 aumf will
turn
20. right i mean so it's just this sense
of momentum and auto
it's almost going to be off its parents
life and you know
health insurance six more years yeah um
is it a question of us not being willing
to
like put the muscle behind what we want
to do because we've spent billions of
dollars in iraq and afghanistan
or is it that these are missions that
are fundamentally misconceived i guess
another way of saying this is you know
what what is your vision of foreign
policy
um is it one where you know the united
states we we've got the best military
we've certainly got the biggest the most
powerful
best looking you know all of that can
they do what they want or is it just
we're we're wrong to be most of the
places we are
i'm going to specifically isolate it in
the places where we are
in to some degree an occupying force
um to me it just it flies in the face of
sustainability
i would like in where i think our
government should strive is to be able
to
function without lurching from crisis to
crisis
but the challenge is you're trying to
apply that requires a long-term view and
requires
diligence and attention and we are
nothing if not attention deficit
and want to forget about things as
quickly as possible and when you look at
the world as a series of problems to
solve
as soon as it's no longer the problem at
the top it just drops at the bottom of
the pile and is off your consciousness
even if it's still there even if people
are still dying even if
things are still happening and we need
to get to the point where we're saying
these are challenges to manage
and here's what we're trying to manage
them towards that sense of strategic
direction is
absolutely lacking and to me if you
don't have a sense of strategic
direction
you hit the reset button you you do the
best you can with what's there
but you stop trying to pretend that
there's some grand vision that you never
had any hopes or even cared to try to
achieve
do you think we should be out of syria
and
out of afghanistan at this point
i think that having a military first
mission in those places
uh has been proven to not be effective i
think we're fundamentally
and i'm glad to see the biden
administration um stopping the support
of offensive attacks in yemen
um but realizing that even like
every single one of these conflicts or
civil wars that we all of a sudden found
ourselves in the middle of
and then supported one side or the other
and sometimes like in iraq
you're supporting one side and then
supporting the other and then going back
and supporting the first side again um
to what act yeah do you have a vision
for how
american foreign policy should be
restructured um
and should it be you know military first
or should it be more
about diplomacy trade and kind of soft
power
definitely soft power but with the hard
edge and
by that i mean we have we have diplomacy
we we utilize
you know development we utilize the fact
that what's in our best interest is
almost always stability instability
tends towards those who film
who fill that vacuum are willing to do
what others won't
and we are bound by a sense of moral
certainty that
um we don't always live up to but i'm
glad we at least pay lip service towards
but at the end of the day if we should
be investing far more in our overseas
intelligence
but not just for the purposes of finding
some dude in a cave and dropping a
hellfire on him but actually
understanding how to navigate and
influence what's going on in the region
rather than just trying to rack up kills
that's what everything tends towards
what you know uh and i i want to get to
the points where um
you know you uh kind of line up pretty
well with i think
a kind of uh general libertarian point
of view but i guess we're
we'll we'll kind of go ask backwards
into that um it's a problematic word in
the third district
um the um uh
you know when it comes to china um how
should you know what what is the goal of
our interaction with china
and you know what is the best way to
achieve
a um you know a kind of relationship
with china which benefits the united
states
but also doesn't destabilize other parts
of the world
i think that that tension is
fundamentally
where our our hope and and frankly of
our naivete over the past two decades
has really come home to roost um
to me it's well when i was in
afghanistan if i bought a rug
and the guy walked away with a smile on
his face i knew that i'd gotten
the worst end of that deal right and
then to me china has been walking away
with a smile on its face and their
interactions with the west
for far too long we've been under this
assumption that um
further prosperity would tend towards
further democracy that trade and
reciprocal arrangements
would lead to a more open society that
would inherently tend towards us
that idea of a democratic consensus
i mean it's just it's political science
fiction what we need to be doing at a
return
is again having a sense of okay where do
we need to go in our bilateral relations
how do we ensure that that respects the
sovereignty of neighboring countries
and how do we also have clear red lines
that can't just be
transgressed with impunity and i think
all too often the u.s talks a really big
game
and then as you saw with obama's red
lion in syria
fails to actually live up to it now i'm
not advocating for taking an inherently
belligerent position
but if you say you're willing to do
something by god you got to do it
so what is china and i guess you know i
i know you are
uh according to your campaign you know
when you were running
you're pro free trade but you have at
various points drawn along and saying
you know what we have with china is not
fair trade because you know we're
letting their goods come in here easily
and they're
blocking us from their markets in
various ways
um so how how do you resolve that um you
know what how do you
how do you um uh you know kind of bring
china to heal yeah well if i had a time
machine it'd be
so much of the intellectual property
theft that has undermined the west i
think it's
as conservative estimates of at least a
trillion dollars in intellectual
property have flowed in one direction
over the past two decades china doesn't
have to invent they can just steal and
modify
and then rush something to market before
you know our companies can
that's something that we need to ensure
i mean that is a part of the trade
right that's not in the open market
that's not going across not a container
ship
it's not counting towards the gdp of
either nation
but that is become a component of the
trade that we need to
we need to cut off we need to isolate
but you can't just have that
be a defensive measure right i mean and
this is where i say
if we're only looking at things that are
military and non-military
if we're not appreciating the fact that
you know
i would love for us to have a perfectly
free trade system
but it also needs to be one that
recognizes that
if we are the only ones giving then we
will be taken advantage of
that there are countries who will resort
to protectionist measures there are
countries that will
operate in an underhanded way and you
need to have accountability mechanisms
and that may not be in the trading world
that may live in other parts of our
our government have accountability
mechanisms that keep that playing field
level
do you feel that china is you know
should we be heavily
backing hong kong in its uh push against
china uh china authoritarianism and is
that part of
the ebb and flow of uh kind of national
relation or international
relations with china why we're not
having the type of visa programs that
the uk
is having right now to allow talent from
hong kong
that wants to relocate that wants to
rebuild that wants to take that talent
that ingenuity
and apply it in a place with the
infrastructure to really let it grow
just makes absolutely no sense to me and
it and so much of our immigration system
seems aimed at pushing out or rejecting
the best and brightest so they can go be
our economic or geopolitical adversaries
uh and i've yet to to understand that
but i mean specifically with hong kong
it's a question
and we have the same question with
taiwan you know we need to hold
firm or else you'll be run over but you
know what's worth starting a war over
um and and to me this is where
i really loathe the fact that many of
our adversaries have a full range of
asymmetric options that are short of war
i mean iran has been at war with us for
40 years
but they've been doing it in such a way
that prevents an open conflagration
and that is to their advantage and we
need to have similar toolkits
um and not just look at the world as as
friends and enemies
but as folks who are going to live in
the gray area between so
in a way i mean trump's you support
trump's
china policy right where he's pushing
back and it seems as if
uh biden is actually kind of holding
fern to a lot of that right
i i should hope so i i i
it's early days and most of what the
biden administration has done has not
had much scrutiny
because the internal skirmishes on my
side of the aisle have been
all-consuming
um i can only imagine what the first
two weeks of the biden administration
would look like if donald trump still
had his twitter account um
you know so that's to your earlier point
one of the challenges is
you know we have the media environment
that's focused on what shines the
brightest
and not what actually generates heat
yeah you know you mentioned
immigration how do you uh and you you're
a proponent of a merit-based immigration
policy
um you know donald trump was you know
frankly
anti-immigration he uh his his
uh administration did everything they
could to reduce ill
legal immigration everybody tries to
block
illegal immigration and that seems to be
kind of outside the ability of
governance really to control the border
uh particularly effectively but what is
your what's your vision of a merit-based
immigration policy yeah i mean right now
our immigration system is like heating
in a new york apartment
right i mean it's either blistering hot
you know or bone cold
and there's no ability to really
modulate it to me
if you think of the strongest argument
against immigration it's
you know there's a safety and security
element on the margins but it's by and
large the fear of american jobs being
replaced when on the whole
immigrants are a net creator of jobs or
a net creator of economic development
i think when the issue is abstracted at
the federal level
when you're trying to appeal to
washington to make those type of
judgments
determinations it's inherently going to
be imprecise
so when i talk about merit-based
immigration when i talk about how our
immigration system would be
i would love to see the states be one of
the drivers
of of identifying what their need is
what their capacity is
and then trying to flip on this head
this fear
that immigrants are going to take
american jobs you know the same folks
who will say that i've had farmers who
come up and they say
you know we have too many immigrants we
need to build the wall but i also need
to figure out how to help out my guys
over here because they're good people
and they've been here the whole time
right that sense of proximity breeds
trust breeds understanding
and that distance conversely creates
fear
creates uh suspicion and that's what
undermines our system as whole
so are you in favor of a kind of
state-based
uh set of immigration quotas and things
like that citizenship would always need
to
lie at the federal level i think that is
that is you know a no-brainer
and you would absolutely need to have um
some degree of caps
but instead of the current system we
have that's just a patchwork since 1965
with a lot of bizarre vestiges
aligning with well what do the
industries in the state need
right if you talk to michigan circa you
know 2012
2014 you know then governor rick snyder
was like for the love of god can we get
some people to help repopulate detroit
some of the most vibrant communities in
the detroit area most vibrant
working-class communities
were composed of of arab immigrants of
yemeni immigrants
of folks who had come from from mexico
and had created senses of of community
and were willing to put in the work to
kind of bring those areas back
right that's not necessarily going to be
the same scenario in los angeles
so having a regional based approach
having states have that input
and ideally getting to a point where
it's not this all or nothing
you're either illegal or you're on a
pathway to citizenship
but something that appreciates the
gradations of the requirements in our
economy today
would put us on a path where we can have
the immigration we need to support our
economy
without having the fear that it's going
to take away jobs from americans
do you overall i mean are you would you
characterize yourself as
uh kind of more open borders rather than
less open borders
you know that more immigrants generally
speaking is better than fewer immigrants
where that appropriate number is i think
is hard for us to calibrate at the
federal level i think
it is plainly evident from many of our
companies today that
immigrants bring a sense of hunger and a
sense of vision
and an idea that can be realized and
achieved
but i'm also aware of some of the
possible negative ramifications
of having a system that doesn't check
against those impulses i mean we're kind
of circling back
to what we were talking about earlier um
with
these these kind of paranoid trends and
that fear of the other and how
that has become so encapsulated in those
two myths that november third was a
landslide election january 6th
was an opportunity to stop that steal
all of that is in that same vein that
same fear that composition of a world
view
that has to be defended and you're going
to latch on to whatever straws you can
you know to build up protections against
the reality would you
vote for uh you know joe biden seems to
be signaling that there's going to be
less enforcement via ice
um and you know things like making
dreamers uh you know people
kids who were brought here by their
parents and don't have clear legal
status
would you vote you know to make somebody
who grew up here and
you know might be in the military might
be working uh whatever
should they have a quick path to
citizenship or should they be deported
i think there's no doubt they need
stabilization in the short term
and then we need to have a broad
discussion on what our immigration
priorities are as country
i mean the i feel like the the
republican party has bounced between
being
open-minded to some um
form of stable policy then retreated
back to nothing
while the democratic party has kind of
moved the goalposts further and further
towards um open borders may be going too
far but at least blanket amnesty and
pathways to citizenship you know across
the board
now as long as you have a poorest
southern border
you're never ever going to be able to
get to the point where your immigration
system has well calibrated your
country's needs
right so i would prefer to see far
more legal immigration and again aligned
with state-based economic requirements
and without understanding that
if states are worried about american
citizens not having the employment
opportunities
that are out there that that could be
solved within that state because they're
going to be most finely attuned
i'd rather have far more of that and i
would also rather we don't have
the sort of gray area system we have
where several of our industries i mean
especially in agriculture and meat
processing
those industries would collapse without
the illegal immigrants that are
you know keeping them propped up with a
wink and a nod i mean that just is a
system that tends towards
abuse um towards just
dark outcomes and mistreatment of
individuals and is ultimately quite
inhumane
what what's your uh what you're feeling
about stimulus spending you're going to
be
you know you're going to be voting on
all of this stuff uh any day now
you know what um should there be uh you
know
massive injections of government
spending into the economy right now
biden is talking about a 1.9 trillion
dollar spending package
if that comes across your you know if
that comes for a vote are you going to
be voting for something like that
it's ultimately going to depend on
what's what's inside
but right now and let's be very honest
the reason why it's 1.9 trillion and not
2 trillion
is so that biden can't be accused of
spending trillions of dollars he wants
to be able to asterisk it right
it was sold for you know 99 cents not a
dollar
i looked at some of the internal
component pieces i
for the life of me don't understand why
we're spending 20 billion dollars on
vaccines
50 billion on testing
give me a bill that spends 200 billion
dollars on testing and gets us to be
able to reopen
in half the time and then we've just
prevented the need for far more of that
economic stimulus that is baking in a
closure of the country that keeps
getting extended further and further
right i mean we have the tools to get to
the end that we need
and yet there's far more of an emphasis
i think
continuing a state of dependency
continuing a state of
government control i'm not presupposing
out of malevolence but
it isn't you know let's sprint as fast
as we can towards the light at the end
of the tunnel
it's well we're already going down the
tracks when you talk to your
uh you know democratic colleagues or
whatever and you say why instead of
talking about spending two trillion
dollars and we spent four trillion
dollars last year
on various forms of stimulus spending
why don't we just throw
you know what would be a massive amount
of money towards testing and vaccinating
people
and open things up and you know what is
their response to that is it like you're
cur you're crazy
or what so i'm actually part of the
bipartisan coalition called the problem
solvers we're trying to get a set aside
package
that says listen you know let's debate
some of the more contentious parts of
the stimulus
and and right away give us a standalone
bill that will have
money for ppe testing and vaccines we'll
get it through slam dunk no issues there
um reality is there's already over a
trillion dollars from the previous
stimulus that hasn't been spent
and so this sense of of urgency
on behalf of the biot administration is
a little bit contrived
but the other reality is that they want
to keep that in the package
so that if republicans bulk at say a
minimum wage of fifteen dollars being
dovetailed within
it's not that it's you voted against
money for vaccines uh let's be
very clear i've talked to folks on the
other side of the aisle
and saying we want to work on a
bipartisan you know package
and they say well we're using budget
reconciliation it can be bipartisan all
you have to do is vote for it
you uh you are the scion uh or uh of
a uh of a major um
superstore chain myers chain founded by
your
grandfather in the early 60s
and its current form um how do you feel
you know they
myers employs a lot of people
who do kind of low
i don't want to say low skill but i mean
it is kind of low skill work
uh clear you know commercial uh work
where are you on a 15 minimum wage
national minimum wage
yeah i think our our stores
restores average wage it's a little bit
different from seasonal and kind of
summertime workers
but it's pretty close to there um i mean
granted we're in michigan ohio
kentucky indiana illinois and wisconsin
so it's not you know wegmans and
virginia and new york uh
but it strikes me that when it comes to
a 15 minimum wage
amazon is totally supportive
you know the larger your company the
more collective bargaining your
employees have the higher your wages are
going to be to begin with
um the more you're happy to embrace a 15
minimum wage because it undermines your
competitors
who don't have those degree of scale i
mean it's creating
barriers to entry in the market it's
frankly creating barriers of entry
to especially young and low-skilled
employees
you know i'm sure robot manufacturers
love it because it makes their products
that much competitively cheaper
but i think it's it's a it's
i mean it's a policy without any strong
rationale
uh or or frankly economic grounding why
15 why not 14.25 why not 1375.
you know 15 is a nice number where are
you on uh climate change
uh is human activity contributing to
climate change and is that something
that the government needs to be
dealing with and if so at what scale
yes and yes i think climate change is
real
um i think we need to be mindful of the
fact that
our carbon emissions are altering you
know how our
planet you know heats and cools itself
um
you know we live in michigan we're
defined
our our state is defined by
its connection to the environment and
the great lakes
we have a large fishery economy i mean
as a country
we are a benefit a beneficiary of our
natural resources
we are a beneficiary of the world as it
is and we need to be mindful of doing
everything we can to steward
it i don't support the green new deal i
don't support
to the earlier points we're saying any
policies that tend towards
centralization socialization
nationalization but we also need to make
sure that we're connecting cause and
effect
that we're holding folks to account who
are polluting while at the same time
creating the incentives
to minimize that and for sure making
sure we're not subsidizing
or underpinning you know industries that
are costing us a lot more
than the benefit they may be providing
does that mean
uh you know one way of reading that is
to say you know we shouldn't be
subsidizing oil and gas manufa
you know makers on another it's maybe we
shouldn't be subsidizing solar panel
uh makers if they're not delivering the
product that
you know they say they're going to um
you know should we be should the
government be in the business of heavily
subsidizing um attempts to create new
forms of energy that would be less
polluted
well i do support you know a lot of the
basic and advanced research
um that has frankly driven a lot of
american economic innovation
uh so i i don't want to kind of go i
want to set that aside
but more broadly you know it can be very
hard to disentangle
the web of subsidies and penalties and
how that creates incentives within a
structure
solar panels have gone down
they tenfold in terms of price per watt
in the past decade that means just
incredible gains in efficiency
no doubt some of that was because of
investments spurred by subsidies
but the challenge is you're operating in
a web of subsidies and in
and it can be very hard to get a
non-distorted view
of efficiency i do believe you have to
bake in
to those costs you know once you pare
down all the subsidies
what are the negative externalities that
you're ultimately going to have to pay
for
right i mean if you have a toxic
chemical on the one hand
that you're selling for cost plus a
small margin but not baking in
the societal impact on the back end of
cleanup
you know you are just setting yourself
up to have those costs be socialized by
the entire country
and that i don't support either i mean
that is where
rationalization must take place where
what is your view of things you know
this was something in the
i guess 2016 election the you know the
foxconn deal in uh
in wisconsin where you know the the
state
local and federal government donald
trump is a big supporter of this people
like scott walker who
at one point bestowed the republican
presidential field as a colossus right
you know they were going to you know
through smart money and
kicking a bunch of homeowners out on
eminent domain we're going to bring in a
big
foreign company that was going to create
you know massive jobs factories
it didn't work in general are you
against
that kind of deal making by
governments at the state local and
federal level well
let me just say to me one of the
greatest problems in our political
system is the maturity mismatch between
short-term electoral incentives of
long-term governing incentives
right so scott walker or anyone can go
up on the dais you can be there at the
ribbon cutting you can get all the kudos
and credit you can ride that to the next
election
um but you're not held accountable when
you know the
project doesn't go through when the
funding is pulled when
you know something goes wrong on the
tail end um
i think especially when it comes to
economic incentives
um on a state by state or regional basis
you know it really becomes
you know mutually assured destruction
you know some of the per
job costs have been you know greater
than the net present value of 10 years
of that
individual salary would have been at
what point you say
why i'm sure there was some fancy study
that was commissioned and said well
you're going to lose money on this
you're going to make money on ancillary
industries coming in
but you start to go down that road and
it to me it's just the definition of
inefficiency
and you're also opening up decision
makers who are not necessarily
incentivized to be finding the right
deals for their state the long term
but are looking for an easy win and a
way of claiming to have created jobs
politicians don't create jobs except for
jobs that probably shouldn't exist in
the first place
does does meyer when you know when you
open a new store and i i lived uh part
and full time in ohio
uh for a number of years so i am very
familiar with meyer which
i have to tell you is a fantastic story
it's a fantastic chain it really really
is but do they go in like walmart and
like target and all of these places and
say to localities hey you know what
we're thinking about moving here but you
know there's this other town on the
other side of the mountain
that is going to you know they say we
won't have to pay taxes they say
you know they'll do all the hookups for
us so we don't have to actually build
out the infrastructure
does meyer compete for that kind of um
you know municipal or state largesse
i'm sure that they do i will be very
honest and that my
only professional experience at the
company has been stocking shelves and
getting carts in the summer so
i've never worked there in an executive
or professional capacity
i have spent time in real estate
development and this is where when it
comes to incentives
i think it's there's a big difference
between here's a grant
right or here's a forgivable loan and
and some of the incentives that are
if you build this store or you do this
development
you know the city or the county or the
state will see
an increase in taxes of x and so
here's a way that you can get access to
a portion of that
so funds that never would have been
created in the first place and could be
clawed back if they aren't created
to me that's in a different category
because it's not taking taxpayer dollars
it's something that wouldn't have
existed in the first place
i don't believe i can't speak to the
company's policies on that but
this is also the problem is if it exists
in a competitive landscape
people are going to take advantage of it
sure um
let's talk about a couple of uh more
social issues or
things that intersect with that um uh
you know and i i
i want to harp on um you know i guess i
admire superstore for uh
this is a positive light they went from
being a
chain that in the early 21st century
was not that highly regarded by various
kinds of lgbt
associations that looked at hiring
practices by 2020 they are considered to
be one of the very best
companies to work for if you are lesbian
gay
bi trans etc um what is your feeling
uh you know in in the republican party
there is a culture war still i mean
the republican party has lost most of
the culture war battles
over things like uh gay rights um
is this is this something the republican
party needs to hang on to
or is this something that they should be
giving up uh
kind of um you know thinking that there
is a state interest
in people's sexual orientation so if i
may just say on the
the company's human rights campaign
lgbtq equality i think it was just lgbt
and then probably q and now i a plus
on that survey were getting very low
scores
back in the day because we weren't
returning the survey and paying the ten
thousand dollars that
you know the folks wanted um i think
ninety percent of the improvement was
just
filling out the survey and complying
with demands and probably maybe 10
percent was evolving personnel policies
oh no
so it's like the u.s news and world
report college rankings it's not
an objective reality check it's more
kind of i'm sure that will come as a
shock to to many recent listeners yeah
that there's
more there's more to those stories um
but specifically
you know to me and this is where i come
back to individual liberties
i have to be equal in the application of
beliefs
and in a content neutral standpoint and
i would rather the government not be
determining
and and not be inserting their nose into
places where there's no compelling state
interest
i i guess i struggle to
reconcile um conservative
beliefs in limited government with this
belief of an imposition
of values because if i believe the
government can impose my values
i'm creating the precedent to it for it
to impose values on the other side as
well
i'm also a very big believer in grace
and then
um you know leave that poor baker alone
you know don't make this a
celeb issue can we just be the the
bigger people here
um but at the end of the day you know i
think the party has pretty solidly moved
away from that and i
give donald trump a lot of credit i
think donald trump was more progressive
on lgbtq issues
in 2017 that barack obama was in 2009.
i mean just how that shifted um
is i think both a recognition of how
much the landscape has changed and also
you know the republican party moving to
where it really should be
yeah uh michigan pass recreational pot
in 2018. are you good with that
i supported uh the legalization of
marijuana um i support at the federal
level on the
you know federal decriminalization and
allowing states to you know choose how
they wish to apply that
um i think
you know it we're in an upside down
system where states are are legalized
and this clearly falls within
traditional police powers that should
live
at the state level um that having been
said i still hold a security clearance
so i
have not been able to partake i was
going to say that was my next question
have you ever used
marijuana or what the government calls
illicit drugs
i think once prior to joining the
military
um and its public record because i put
it on my security clearance adjudication
form that the chinese hacked in 2013
anyways so
um i can't say that i was ever actually
high though um
so that is not an experience that is not
necessary
you know i've read that in michigan
possession of ecstasy or mdma and
and basically any amount could lead to
10 years in jail
is that a problem that needs to be
addressed
i i know this is solidly within your
wheelhouse but it's
pretty firmly out of mind um
you know i i do think that pairing up
negative societal or health consequences
um with with legal infractions is right
and rational i think we've been moving
towards that and frankly
on a lot of criminal justice issues
michigan has been in a very good
position
um we did away with most forms of cash
bail but
unlike new york we're smart enough to
have some judicial inputs you didn't
have
you had scenarios where there was
discretion uh we moved towards
expungement laws where prior we still
had expungement but you had to actively
go and petition and
you could get someone to do it for you
for a couple of hundred bucks but what
you were doing is leaving behind folks
you know who otherwise you know couldn't
afford that and so it was
um there was a disparate impact and
moving towards a system where
you still have a judge being able to
ultimately say well there's a public
um good being served by keeping this on
the record but also allowing folks who
had
moved on or who had you know minor
infractions that weren't of an enduring
nature
to be able to rebuild and move on with
their lives um
i can't speak to where we should go on
on other recreational substances though
that's
uh again a little out of my wheelhouse
talking about criminal justice reform
you know this i mean the the past year
has been
you know a year of covet and lockdowns
and i want to get your opinion on some
of that
but also on criminal justice reform and
particularly
um racially disparate impacts and and
kind of
outrage at the way policing is done do
you think
uh and and this is also something that
donald trump's
temper tantrum really kind of obscured
which is that in
you know in this past election trump did
better uh
than average much better than average uh
and increased his
showing among blacks and latinos um
you know what does the republican party
what should it be doing
to broaden its appeal to people of color
that what you just said always it
cracked me up so much when i would knock
on
a door in a you know predominantly white
upper-class suburb
and have someone yelling at me that
donald trump was a racist
and then i would go to you know a ward
in the city
and find folks who loved him and and it
was
just such a mismatch because um
for any number of reasons but i think we
were talking a little bit ago i mean one
of the things that i took away from the
november third election
was wow the country
is maybe a little bit tired of donald
trump certainly isn't in love with joe
biden
um but definitely doesn't like nancy
pelosi i mean it was this this kind of
blended response and i think that's what
a very bipolar politics often obscures
is things in the middle so you have
trends
like um trump strongly over performing
in the rio grande valley in texas
especially among hispanics which again
has someone
who you know went to nyu and lives in
brooklyn right now no offense i did my
mba at nyu and went to undergrad at
columbia so i can talk smack on these
folks
um if they think that you know if they
think that that is something in the
realm of possibility right
because there's a very big difference
between being extremely online
and seeing a stronger economy even with
the pandemic
and i think that's where when we pay too
much
attention to the noise and not as much
attention to what is occurring
um we can lose sight of that and and now
you can also lose sight
of what will occur by ignoring the noise
and that's what we saw in the lead up to
january 6th
but the gop absolutely needs to build on
on that record of thing you know if you
actually
talk honestly with folks if you reach
out to them if you
if you are engaged in an honest
conversation they don't want to have a
disposition on diversity equity
and inclusion initiatives you know they
want to hear about how you're going to
serve them as you would
serve anyone else in the country what do
you think
you know contributed to trump uh doing
better than a typical republican i mean
he certainly did much better than john
mccain or mitt romney among minorities
and he did better
the second time than his first time um
is it
uh school choice is it uh general
economic growth what were the
you know what were the things that had
him make gains among
communities that you know if you listen
to the media
he has you know he has completely
alienated because he's the face of white
supremacists
i would say shocking transparency um
you know the belief that here was a
fighter
my wife is an immigrant um you know
watching her parents especially kind of
where
she for brazil from brazil um
going through the process of of getting
their citizenship
of seeing that pathway um you know they
had a very difficult upbringing um and
and so viewing politics is something
that happens
to you not something you can participate
in i think is the frame set that a lot
of folks who immigrate to this country
you know naturally arrive at and so then
getting that sense of agency becoming
more informed
um you know there are you know i think
trump if anything was a challenger of
assumptions in
so many regards and that's where
especially
um you know a immigrant to the country
might feel well
trump doesn't like immigrants or the
democratic party is the party we should
belong to
and then you kind of scratch the surface
and say well
i haven't really seen really great
immigration policies there's a lot of
talk but not necessarily the action
and i think over time you know
mitt romney wasn't saying why the hell
are you voting for a democrat
we got better policies what have they
ever done for you and donald trump did
and actually forced that question and i
think some asked themselves that and
came to a
different answer than expected you know
a traditional split in congress and in
talking to you this
i mean it it seems to me to be rising
more and more to the surface
the traditional spitting con is split in
congress and you know politics is
between
conservatives and liberals republicans
and democrats
there's also a generational divide that
seems to be growing
um the i looked this up before talking
with you
the average age in the senate is like 61
or 62 years old the average age in the
house is about
58. you are 33 right
so you i mean you're like a full
generation 25 years
below the average how does is there
what is the the ground of generational
solidarity i mean what
you you on many levels have nothing in
common with
aoc or ilhan omar or you know young
you know young people uh on the left but
in another way it seems like you have
more in common with them
than you might with uh you know a nancy
pelosi or
even a kevin mccarthy who years ago was
calling himself one of the young guns i
think he's the last of the young guns
still in office
but you know is there is there a
generational split and if so what are
the axes along that
uh yeah i'd say one of the most
challenging things about covid
is building those relationships has been
hard
i've made some kind of in passing but
our new member orientation was distance
to mast
and you have a delta where you know the
democrats you know view it as
um a point of partisan pride to be a
thousand percent covet compliant
and you know i'm i'm like 90
right i mean i have no issue wearing a
mask when i'm in an indoor confined
space if i'm walking by myself outdoors
you know when someone gives me a dirty
look it's like okay we should be
triaging our response here
um but then i have colleagues who are
uh let's just say you know firmly on the
other side of that issue and view
any restriction as an unabridgable on a
sale
assailant of their constitutional rights
um
so it's been hard to have the degree of
interaction to actually build those
relationships
but i think your earlier point and this
is what will never stop being
fascinating to me is that
um the top three house republicans are
54 or 55
the top three house democrats are 80 or
81
and i might be 81 and 82 right now i
haven't double checked those birth dates
but
there is a big difference in
sort of where the average age is on the
democratic side and where their
leadership is
and then where the average age and the
leadership is on the republican side so
i think you're going to see
especially once we get past i'm sure
there'll be
polarizing political moments but as
donald trump
isn't the lightning rod around which
all the earth spins apologies for the
next metaphor
um you're going to see alliances
starting to shift and form
and frankly the impeachment vote on the
republican side of the house
was that in a nutshell where the
ideological lines blurred
pretty firmly um you had you had
moderates you had folks who were much
more
foreign policyhawks you had folks all
across the spectrum those on the more
libertarian side
that line kind of got blurred and there
was a uniting around
principle around a belief in fidelity to
the constitution
around you know serving an oath of
office that to me
kind of showed what our politics kind of
could be when we don't let those
more abstract lines divide us in the
first place
um you know can we talk a little bit
about your upbringing i mentioned you're
the
grandson of the founder of the meyer
superstore chain um what was it like to
grow up
wealthy um and but also
geared towards commerce where you know
you know the base
i mean the way myers gets bigger is by
serving more people at cheaper
uh prices with better service um you
know what what was your child look
hood like and how does that uh factor
into your worldview and your politics
boy um you know obviously it's
on a personal level a little bit bizarre
to
you know try to reconcile your
individual self
with a family that has a place in the
community with you know a
um with folk with trying to
place and situate and build confidence
and then create an identity that both
includes but is also separate from um
i mean to me at the end of the day it
was
you know seeing how much an institution
can reward people who are with
inside of it how it can serve folks who
are outside of it uh and how those
that ability to channel energy um and
towards a productive outcome
uh can create a beneficial multiplier
effect
yeah you mentioned grace in passing and
you come from
a part of the country and a part of
michigan and a part of the country
that is rich in a uh dutch reformed a
calvinist
religious sensibility uh what are what
is your you know what how what is your
faith
and um you know how does that inform how
you go about your
uh work as a congressman yeah it's it's
interesting west michigan
it's very you know
a lot of a lot of overwhelming you know
christian reform church
you know beliefs it's conservative but
it
you know it's both receptive to refugees
and very involved
in international humanitarian aid um
it's strongly supportive in beliefs of
redemption
um and of returning to society and
criminal justice reform
right it doesn't necessarily cut cleanly
along
partisan lines so much as this is about
investment in the community of service
of of kind of loving thy neighbor um and
viewing
your role um and faith as as being
something that's exercised in acts right
not just in speech not just
in word but in how you carry yourself in
the world as well
but uh to get a little theological you
are not preaching a covenant of works
right i assume you are still firmly in a
covenant of grace but you uh but you do
good works that
yes well and and i you know there's some
uh
um she did so i did not grow up in the
christian reform church um i i very much
enjoyed listening
to to arguments going back to
um some of the uh to kuiper
um and some of the old few or some of
the theologians that were seminal
um in in
um oh boy i'm so out of my depth in this
current moment
um but at least we're about generating
the world that you grew up in right
yeah um what is it like to be a dutch
american
um because that seems you know it's it's
among the earliest colonial forces
presences here but it's you know been
minimized um
i don't know is there is there something
about being dutch american that uh
you you want to uh bring to uh to view
right now
um frugality and thriftiness would
probably be the easiest stereotypes
the biggest impact of being a dutch
american in my life is that
unless someone's from the midwest they
probably can't pronounce my last name
so that's always enjoyable to uh to kind
of see them go through that process but
i mean i think i'm a quarter dutch
30 german um though among
among my family uh going back to
great grandparents i think i had
one out of eight that was in the u.s
before
1900 so it was kind of more recent wave
of immigration and that was a lot of the
folks in west michigan came across
you know i think the joke is that most
people leave their country because
it's too you know politically
conservative and they come to the u.s to
seek more of a liberty
live more liberty and with the dutch it
was the opposite that the netherlands
were too politically liberal and they
wanted to go and
have a more conservative environment as
a final topic of conversation you've
you've talked uh at various places and
we've hinted at it in this conversation
about
the need to restore trust and confidence
in institutions
uh can you talk a little bit about what
what is the level of breakdown that you
see
and then where are the places especially
that we need to start
building trust back and how do we go
about doing that yeah i think you can
broadly put that breakdown
into just a sense
of of epistemological epistemological
certainty
right in terms of our knowledge
structure how we view the world how
we've
arrived at a truth um and then also
how we reconcile disagreements or
resolve
disputes in a civilized society
the former is the balkanization of our
media landscape you know the creation of
echo chambers which is nothing new
and though to me it's uh alway it's
especially shocking
because i go between those chambers i
know there's a far right echo chamber
there's a center right echo chamber
there's a right echo chamber
there is a centrist echo chamber and
then you know vice versa on the other
side
um but i think and we've seen this over
the past
nine months especially uh and i think
this underpinned the riots that we saw
over the summer
uh and it also underpinned the storming
of the capital this belief that
all of the institutions we rely on
whether the
whether those that help us define our
world like the media or academia
or those that we view as a way that we
can be agents of change
you know politics the courts
all society more broadly that there's
something
fundamentally corrupt and that those
those pathways are blocked that the
system is
raped that there's no point in engaging
in them so you go outside
right that's why and i remember having
this conversation with local law
enforcement leaders during
the black lives matter protest which
resulted in a you know a destructive
riot in grand rapids that
uh had about half a million dollars in
property damage you know their question
was
what do we do right i mean what do they
want like
grand rapids didn't have you know there
have been some regrettable incidents but
you know there was no george floyd
moment in the city of grand rapids
um you know a lot of the the frustrated
outcomes
were actually being slowly worked upon
and improved through criminal justice
reform and any number of other
initiatives to try to
correct historic injustices and in their
present day incarnations
you know so that sense of disconnect
between the passion
and the achievable outcome invariably
breeds
distrust and so that's where the
violence you know comes into the system
so how do how do you start um you know
how do you start restoring that uh
if you you know if you look back 50
years is
you know it's partly because it's when
we started uh
polling and surveying this type of stuff
but you know it's been almost a
straight-line decline in
all sorts of confidence in institutions
public and private
uh even uh you know third space like the
catholic church
is less trusted than it was 50 years ago
the united way is less trusted than it
was 50 years ago along with the
government and with big business and
whatnot
um you know how do you how do you how do
you
change that um you know what what are
what are things that you can be doing
i mean you abolish section 230 and have
government-imposed information
um you know i mean frankly what you have
to do is
connect cause and effect right i mean
and that's where
the ability to weasel out of
accountability and to always
cast blame means that nobody's ever
ultimately held responsible because it's
a rhetorical exercise it's that there's
no accountability if a um if somebody in
the military is bad at their job people
die
right you can't deny if they're alive or
dead if a business executive does a poor
job
the company doesn't earn a profit or
goes bankrupt those are
concrete states in politics there's no
real concrete state
and when there's a negative outcome you
can always find a way to
cast that blame outward so how do you
solve that in my mind
is you need to collapse things down you
need to be focusing on
the lowest levels of government possible
it's a lot easier to hold a mayor
accountable for the budget
that they worked on with the city
commission if it doesn't line up
because they don't have any choice but
to resolve that dispute and you can see
the tangible benefits
what are the tangible benefits at the
federal level i mean yes we have we have
security maybe you get a check in your
mailbox
but the more abstract those entities are
the harder it is to connect their value
and the harder it is to hold them
accountable when they don't live up to
the promise that's been
uh fulfilled well we're going to leave
it there uh
thank you representative peter meyer of
michigan's third district the
uh the seat held by
not only gerald ford but justin amash
more recently peter meyer thanks for
talking to reason
thank you nick deeply appreciate it